with
CP3 let's just right to it Chris when
you got the phone call the opportunity
to come play with the Warriors what went
through your mind um I was excited first
and foremost I was excited to be closer
to my family you know uh of course my
mind went to like dang it's crazy you
know the way we done we done battled for
some years but um you know I was excited
and then once I got here got a chance to
see the guys and know the guys a lot
better uh it's been really really good
was talking to Steve and Steve said this
is a good problem to have to have six
guys to try to fin in five spots but
being a veteran team everybody wants to
win so it makes this process a lot
better that you see the same way yeah
absolutely you know we got a a great
group of guys and you know we talk um
and our our biggest thing is we going to
figure it out I think it's dope when you
get guys together that all got one
common goal and that's the of course
these guys have won here and I haven't
but um you know trying to figure out
what that look looks like and trying to
do any and everything to win it's a it's
a it's a good problem to have right the
voice of the team you know who that is
he says I want Chris Paul to be Chris
Paul I don't want Chris Paul to come
here and be someone else that's from the
voice of this team I think people need
to understand that that's who you are
you play this game at a high level
you're an Allstar you're a Olympic
champion like you've been there before
when the voice of the team says that
does that give you extra motivation to
be you um I definitely appreciate that
you know but uh I think I got a track
record of the last 19 years you know
what I'm saying of playing a certain way
and and when I say playing a certain way
I'm not talking about the style I'm
talking about with an intensity or
whatnot and with one goal and that's to
try to help make my team better so came
in here with that same mindset and uh
yeah it's going to be it's going to be
fun take the fans to what you did this
summer to get your body ready we know
your body's been through a lot last few
years but mentally how did you you say
to yourself this year I'm going make
sure I can stay as healthy as possible
uh just worked out trained uh spent some
time with my my family try to make sure
your mind right you know a lot of lot of
people haven't been through this many
Summers and playing or whatnot so uh
just try to make sure everything is is R
right with the mind uh to go along with
the body and how much have you had a
chance to talk to Clay Steph just the
the core of this team knowing that they
want to get back to the finals we just
spent some really good time together uh
throughout the summer uh not just those
guys but our whole group and you know
with Camp starting I think we'll get a
chance to spend a little bit more time
it's just you know when you got a
veteran team during the summer uh that's
guys's time yeah you know what I mean we
saw you working out Draymond getting up
shots we seen you you know trying to
integrate yourself in the system is huge
but we we tried to find time to get
together but didn't try to force it you
know cuz during the summer that's guys
time to get with their families and
stuff like that but when we got time
together uh we made sure it was
purposeful last one for you I know
you're historian of this game with all
the movement in the west scene with the
Lakers and Phoenix I mean the West is
deep and of course you're still trying
to chase the different nuggets how how
big is that the West is going to be so
deep this year uh 19 years for me I've
been in the west my whole career that's
unbelievable whole career so that's
unbelievable yeah Ain ain't nothing
really changed it's it's it's been the
Wild Wild West since I came in I
appreciate you st my man stay healthy
and I can't wait to see you get out
there yes sir I appreciate you yeah yes
sir yes sir baby